الطائرا البريطانيه تحلق فوق القطاع اليمن
يرد ويستهدف سفنا حربيه واخرى تجاريه في
البحر الاحمر تل ابيب قد تواجه هزيمه
استراتيجيه في القطاع هكذا اعلنتها الدفاع
الامريكيه مؤشر جديد على تفاقم الخلاف في
الحكومه العبريه الالاف يتظاهرون في تلبيب
للاسبوع الثامن على التوالي الزحف البري
يعود من جديد في القطاع ومجلس النواب
الامريكي يطالب باقاله بايدن فما الس
لتعقب غواصات الصين تحالف اوكوس يلجا
لسلاح جديد هيئه الاركان الامريكيه لا
يمكن حل الصراع الاوكراني عسكريا وحلف
الناتو يصرح استعدوا لسماع اخبار سيئه من
اوكرانيا ازمات
الكيان على غير العاده اعلنتها امريكا هذه
المره وعلى لسان وزير الدفاع الامريكي
لويد اوستون الذي قال خلال كلمه القاها في
منتدى ريغان للدفاع الوطني المنعقد هذه
الايام في كاليفورنيا ان تلبيب قد تواجه
هزيمه استراتيجيه في القطاع في الداخل
العبري وفي مؤشر على تفاقم الخلاف اشار
نتنياهو الى رفض وزير دفاعه اف جلاند
مشاركته في المؤتمر الصحفي الذي عقد قبل
يومين بقاعده كيريا العسكريه في تل ابيب
قائلا انه اختار ما اختار فيما تظاهر
الالاف في كافه انحاء الكيان مطالبين
بالافراج فوري عن الرهائن العبريين الذين
تحتجزهم الفصائل في القطاع وتضامنا مع
عائلاتهم للاسبوع الثامن على التوالي ومع
عوده القتال في القطاع اعلن المدير العام
للمكتب الاعلامي الحكومي في القطاع مقتل
اكثر من 700 مواطن في القطاع خلال 24 ساعه
اثر الغارات العبريه فيما ذكرت صحيفه
نيويورك تايمز نقلا عن مصدر ان تلبيب
تعتزم تنفيذ عمليه عاليه الكثافه في
القطاع في الاسابيع المقبله وبعد ذلك قد
يخف القتال الى مرحله اقل حده هناك اعلنت
اذاعه الجيش العبري ان القوات العبريه
بدات بالعمليات البريه شمال خانيونس في
جنوب القطاع بينما افادت باصابه 11 عبريا
بينهم ثمانيه جنود في اطلاق صاروخ من جنوب
لبنان على بيت هيلل بالجليل الاعلى في
التدخلات الدوليه ذكرت صحيفه تيليغراف ان
سفينه مملوكه لبريطانيا وترفع علامات جزر
البهامه تم ضربها اثناء ابحارها في مياه
البحر الاحمر من جانب اخر قالت وزاره
الدفاع الامريكيه في بيان ان سفينه حربيه
امريكيه والعديد من السفن التجاريه تعرضت
لهجمات في البحر الاحمر مما قد يمثل
تصعيدا كبيرا في سلسله من الهجمات البحريه
في الشرق الاوسط ليعلن المتحدث باسم
القوات المسلحه اليمنيه ان قواتهم البحريه
استهدفت سفينتين عبريت في باب المندب وهما
سفينه يونيتي اكسبلورر وسفينه نمبر 9
بالعوده الى بريطانيا وفي وقت سابق اعلنت
وزاره الدفاع البري برطانيه ان الجيش
البريطاني سيقوم برحلات استطلاعيه فوق
القطاع للمساعده في تحديد اماكن الرهائن
الذين تحتجزهم الفصائل لترد الفصائل ان
هذا يجعل لندن شريكه في جرائم الجيش
العبري ومسؤوله عن المجازر التي يتعرض لها
شعب القطاع ومن حرب البحر الى الحرب
البارده حيث لجئ تحالف اوكاس للذكاء
الاصطناعي لتعقب غواصات الصين وذلك باعلان
وزراء دفاع الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا
واستراليا عزمهم ادخال خوارزميات الذكاء
الاصطناعي في اطقم مقاتلات المراقبه
البحريه والهجوميه لمعالجه البيانات التي
تجمعها اجهزه السونار تحت الماء بسرعه
عاليه ما يمكن الحلفاء من مراقبه وتعقب
الغواصات الصينيه بدقه ومواجهه نفوذ بيكين
البحري المتنامي وفقا لبلوم بررج هذا
واعلن مدير القياده السيبرانيه الامريكيه
الجنرال بول ناكاسوني ان نفوذ روسيا
والصين في نصف الكره الغربيه يشكل تهديده
الرئيسيه على امن الولايات المتحده على
المدى الطويل في سياق اخر قال رئيس مجلس
النواب الامريكي مايك جونسون ان السحب
الثقه من الرئيس جو بايدن ضروري لان البيت
الابيض يعرقل التحقيق في جرائم ارتكبها
افراد من
عائلته قناعه
غربيه طالت الحرب ام قصرت فالنتيجه واحده
هنا اكد رئيس هيئه الاركان الامريكيه
تشارلز براون انه لا يمكن حل اي بما في
ذلك النزاع الاوكراني بالسبل العسكريه
وحدها بل يتطلب ذلك ايجاد حل دبلوماسي
واضاف براون ان الولايات المتحده تسعى الى
تجنب الصراع المسلح مع الصين لكنها مستعده
له من جانبه قال الرئيس السابق لوكاله
الاستخبارات المركزيه السي اي اي ديفيد
بترايوس ان اوكرانيا لم تتمكن من تحقيق
اختراق خلال الهجوم المضاد بسبب التاخير
في توريد الاسلحه الغربيه ليصرح الامين
العام لحلف شمال الاطلسي ينس ستولتنبرج ان
الوضع في اوكرانيا قد يتدهور ويصبح اسوا
بسبب عدم كفايه المساعده من جانب الدول
الغربيه لنظام كياف مضيفا استعدوا لسماع
اخبار سيئه من اوكرانيا فيما اشار ضابط
الاستخبارات الامريكي السابق سكوت ريتر
الى ان الغرب بدا يدرك استحاله انتصار
اوكرانيا في الحرب لذلك تتزايد مطالبه
كياف بقبول التسويه مع تخليها عن الاراضي
التي خسرتها على ارض الميدان كشفت وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه في تقرير اليومي ان القوات
الاوكرانيه خسرت نحو 750 عسكريا على مختلف
محاور القتال خلال 24 ساعه بينما قال
الكسندر سافشوك رئيس المكتب الصحفي
لمجموعه قوات وسط الروسيه ان هذه القوات
تمكنت من التصدي لهجمات شنتها ثلاثه الويه
ميكانيكيه تابعه للقوات الاوكرانيه على
اتجاه كراسنو لي مانسكي واشار سفت شوك الى
ان خسائر العدو خلال ذلك بلغت اكثر من 100
من القوميين المتطرفين الاوكرانيين
واستسلم ثمانيه منهم